it's time for screen junkies movie
fights what's going on everybody its
movie fights hashtag movie fights live
hoot-hoot
where my howls at hashtag owl Nation
hashtag to hooligans
let's fly we're here for another edition
of movie fights and we have got quite a
table of competitors right here right
now let's meet our combatants Josh you
know we're doing an a you know from
Collider the the all over the schmoes
Schmo down perry member off hello giving
me a little too much Motown credit I
mean I know you smell around yeah not
exactly like that but uh yeah there's I
guess suppose my wife she won a Jurassic
Park Schmo down that is a instant
classic it is like a macular reception
of the Schmo down it's incredibly
reduced myself to Jurassic Park and also
screams Schmo downs if that's ever on
the table I will play again know what
people have their focus their specialty
so like if there's ever you know they
ever I mean the dress park universe is
like it's gonna keep going so I'm in
good shape
you have your bailiwick they're second
oh he is the titular character of the
josh mokuba show also he is if Alex
Trebek and the powers-that-be merv
griffin enterprises
I know it's good for them the next host
of Jeopardy
Josh mccoon goes up al Qaeda be back man
I've seen movies since the last time
none of them which were directed by Ava
Duvernay oh yeah remember you you argue
for able to do very no need to do
something then during the question you
really you revealed that never seen any
Ava Duvernay director yeah that's true
and also I think Billy at the what when
I said what I didn't see the movie like
big his head I was like always good to
have you back products buddy and this
gentleman is the host of the only stupid
answers podcast welcome back DJ hey DJ
[Applause]
what's what goes on your podcast we just
talk about movies comic books TV shows
everything everything we love do you
want on dragons and whether they're real
or not a couple weeks back so you know
just whatever the moon moves us I mean
the answer is yes yeah gila monsters
people apparently had seen them over a
town it was a thing what I know okay so
you see there are no dumb questions only
stupid answers money you know I
awesome thanks for being back thanks for
coming back thanks being here thanks for
having me
so this show the questions are decided
by myself and everybody over there on
the Dan cam he is our fact checker
extraordinaire and also a a judge of the
questions Dan Merle yes he will be
giving his opinion he'll be weighing in
with his thoughts dan what's what's got
you excited to coming out this weekend
this weekend yeah well I did not I son I
saw night school and did not enjoy it so
that had me very excited
I'm excited it doesn't go this weekend
but I get to see bad times at the El
Royale tonight we're gonna review on
screener news tomorrow and I decided to
see it because it looks good yeah I feel
like that one could go any either way go
the other way that's one of those movies
have a great cast yeah that's all I can
say that's what I'm excited about is to
find out about that I look forward to
hearing yeah thank you sir
and he is stepping in for Danielle
he is he will be the voice of the people
today Ryan O'Toole hey people hey sorry
curves in your voice today Danielle is
doing other work but thanks for having
me out yeah Ryan can you explain to them
how exactly that business is gonna be
work on my shirt can you guys we're
gonna be voting each round the first
three rounds and you could vote using
the iCard in the top right corner of
your screen we right above get over here
to do that you got to either refresh
after each question or you turn your
annotations off and on again and the
Settings tab I asked in the chat will be
more than happy to help yeah we'll get
everyone up in the vote we'll make sure
you get it and make sure you vote on the
best arguments towels yes people should
know that if you were going to open up
the clock that is screen junkies Ryan is
the van inside twisting the gears and
keeping everything he's our Content
Manager that's Ryan so oh yeah House of
the clock and its walls reference there
no but let's yes screams ooh keys where
a house Ryan is the clock in its wall
tremendous and that would make you Kate
Blanchet that's correct
great Ryan thank you for being here
holding it down
we have great faith good serve so just
we don't have a jte today so GT if
you're out there and you're out there
somewhere but if you're watching please
get well soon
Billie biz in the booth oh and I want to
introduce one new friend we have a new
friend today dan did you know that this
is Percival the owl and he'll be telling
us what each round is over that day what
would we do so real quick there are
three regular round questions and then
we go into the speed round the top two
players and the first three regular
round questions will move on to the
speed round once we hit that speed round
it's anybody's game you'd be down 3-0
and come back in that speed round now I
remember
yeah you already had some fun I'm ready
for this shirt hey Billy Billy bear all
that beautiful bean footage
I Thank You Thor alright question number
one you guys for movie seasons here yeah
grab a pumpkin spice latte and go to the
movies good so here's our question what
will the big hit of the fall movie
season be what will it be and we're
gonna start off with player number one
parry number off
all right probably no surprise here for
anybody who knows my taste is Halloween
and I could say that with a whole lot of
confidence because I haven't just seen
it once I've seen it twice and the movie
is the perfect balance of fanservice and
a nice continuation of that story for
folks who love the Halloween franchise
but then there's also some really well
woven in exposition that'll catch
everybody else up if you're not into
Halloween yet and then when you consider
the fact that this movie is coming out
October 19th right before Halloween I
see you doing the judging face already
am i scaring you is that the problem is
good-bye you I just get scared by things
I make you go see this movie because the
movie is excellent it's already tracking
it's something like fifty five million
dollars I think the production budget on
this one it's something like 10 million
this is going to crush it and it's gonna
reinvigorate the Halloween franchise all
right Thank You Perry coming in with
Halloween Mooka I'm gonna go on a
completely different angle but part of a
franchise in Creed - I think Creed - the
trailer that dropped yesterday might be
my favorite trailer I've seen in the
last two years of any movie I love this
trailer I love the first Creed I didn't
think that's an I'm a die-hard Rocky fan
and I may be a little bit of a Homer on
this one but I think that the rocky
franchise is a franchise that since the
70s has never really taken a hit except
for Rocky 5 and even then there were
parts of rocky 5 really it's not that
bad and to reinvigorate it with a whole
new person as far as the boxer goes but
to keep the original rockiness to it and
be able to make a sequel that should be
hokey and stupid in everything and make
it
that makes this movie look absolutely
bonkers good makes me think that Creed 2
could be the movie that brings those
casual Rocky fans back to the theaters
creed 2 I think will be the movie then
when all the dust settles at the end of
the fall he's gonna be standing in the
mountaintop screamin Makuta Creed -
taking that title DJ yes oh I'm going
with a little bit of a dark horse here
it's very nice of you guys to choose new
iterations of long-running franchises
but that why not why not celebrate
something that is new something that
we're gonna be talking about in the
future something that's not gonna just
get lost within the gray matter of other
franchises I'm talking about the night
comes for us it's coming to Netflix in
the middle of October I also had the
benefit of seeing this movie at
Fantastic Fest I can tell you great
still by the way I can tell you this
movie will blow your mind this is a
movie that won't just blow people's
minds and the fall season this is a
movie that we're going to be talking
about for a long time now a reunites
reunites joe taslim and I cut loose from
the raid and the action is something
that nothing that is coming out the rest
of year will be able to compete and this
is something that people will be
watching and talking about for years to
come Wow ok fight it out y'all as much
as I'm excited for the night comes for
us which I've only heard wonderful
things about
it's a Netflix movie you give me the
definition of a big hit on Netflix
because I don't think that somebody
people talking about people watching
about it people people watching it well
into the future I can also say Fantastic
Fest I did not see Halloween because
another movie I want to seek was
competing against that however a
reception was mixed and so I don't know
if that equals big big box office this
year Halloween it is another iteration
of a franchise that's David Gordon Green
if I remember correctly well so give us
your highness and and I can only imagine
people coming out of theater with mixed
feelings as well on as far as Cretu goes
one of the things that no man
one amazing who was ryan coogler and
he's not a part of the franchise anymore
so this could just be another sequel he
is a part of the franchise in spirit
just like Rocky is because I think that
rocky by the end of the movie he might
be dead and as like a ghost that's
beside the point
listen I don't know what your movie is
yeah I've never even heard of this movie
so you're coming at me we're throwing
like a screwball covered in blueberry
jam that's a sports reference and I'm
sorry that's okay
what what I am excited about with your
movie is the rain thing but I'm with
Perry on this one listen you throw it on
Netflix it's just like a pinchable
series the only way it's gonna rise to
the top is if everybody's talking about
it
yes I I don't think they are I don't
think that the mass appeal of that movie
and then put on Netflix amongst nailed
it and the great British British Bake
Off and all that kind of stuff
it's me able to rise to the top as a
movie that people are me talking about
in the fall I mean the rave guys that's
still I nice franchise for a lot of
people Fantastic Fest is about people
that like to say the word fantastic at
the Paramount laundering in beer I mean
was a part of Fantastic Fest where you
have all the genre fent and it was also
a part of TIFF of all the things that's
where you go and you have the confidence
that it's going to crush it it's like
buying your way into college like my dad
will be he'll own a building let's put
them a Kouga library on it let me get
Halloween when your movie only cost 10
million dollars to make and you're about
to make 55 million plus I guess you have
money to throw around it's not gonna get
lost in the shuffle because of the whole
retcon thing you're going straight from
the first Halloween the original that
made the franchise as special as it is
to continuing the story in this morning
I'm talking about here as someone who
has seen both your what is significantly
better than the other your rose-colored
glasses when Halloween right now we're
going like straight to a burgundy got
something like an 85 on Rotten Tomatoes
yeah but those are all just horror fans
gone once we've gone into November and
everybody's done drinking pumpkin spice
and there's site for that Duncan
Christmas doughnut they're gonna be like
the who cares about who cares about
Halloween are you kidding me cream two
is the movie that figure-eight the
boxing fights I would say Stephen cable
jr. is gonna make junior my point
exactly the cream franchise is now
launching from an already established
perfection of rocky into a movie and a
you know in a boxing arena don't we have
CC who is up against its going up
against Green Book Ralph breaks the
internet and Robin green book TIFF TIFF
it won the Audience Award that is gonna
be a huge food crowd-pleaser movie going
is like good one TIFF let me go to by
the local Cineplex her kids they're like
groans we're gonna see record you're
from now two years from now people are
gonna be like oh man what was your
favorite Creed movies the first one boys
your favorite Halloween movie the first
one what have we been will still be a
movie people be watching their darlings
watching movie from the guys who did the
ring don't be watching it they'll be
talking about it it'll be something that
matters to people will be so an action
movie to them not the night the night
didn't come for them and they're gonna
wonder they're gonna hope that that
money that they spent on the movie comes
back movies having to spend the money
it's on Netflix I'll still be there
again it's one layered muscle
oh man I think we're off Burnett told me
on average people see one movie a year
all right guess what it's gonna be on
Netflix they don't have to decide like
I'm gonna see a guy that gave us your
highness the biggest hit here and I
don't know how to quantify a big hit on
Netflix I don't assign dollars and cents
that Halloween is gonna bring it only
going up against serenity and who knows
anything about serenity
I'm quantifying hit by something that
will continue to matter past the end of
this fall something moviegoers will
still be talking about still be
interested in your you are proving my
point for me create - so many people are
so excited for Korea - based off Creed
which came out a year and a half ago
whenever that came out I don't know
facts I just know opinions okay and what
I do know is it creep - we've been
jonesing for what happened to Ivan Drago
he was the Siberian nightmare this said
we are Siberian nightmare Merle you're
gonna help out down the deaths from
above and then rocky comes out him and
in this trailer he says he knocked
things of me that haven't been fixed
since you're talking about one of the
greatest villains in the history of
movies the greatest villains in the
history of movies an Ivan Drago coming
back and training his son to fight
Rocky's Protege and you just know that
Rocky's probably gonna die in this movie
so this is gonna be the movie that rocky
finds your really big
I guarantee you he's gonna die and
they're like oh my god rocky died
straight into February April I gives you
see Josh I want you to go ahead and roll
this into your final thoughts okay okay
yeah Creed to is is the kind of thing
that we talked about when we were on the
playground and we're like who would
fight Drago what are Drago's kids like
what's it like growing up in headliner
communist still torn Russia that Putin
is keeping under an iron fist and now we
have that answer we have that answer
Adonis Creed he's now fighting for a
family just like in Rocky four when
Adrian scream you know he's got a kid
and he's got a wife and he's fighting
for something that is new he is fighting
for the pride he's fighting for his
father who was killed by this man this
is redemption in the ring this isn't
redemption via guns or anything else
this is redemption with its purest form
fists covered in foam covered in leather
with Everlast written on it that is
Creed - this is the ultimate redemption
villain back franchise everything
together it makes it perfect Creed - all
right I admire your passion Thank You
Josh DJ listen Creed here's the thing
you haven't seen Creed she's seen
Halloween I've seen the night comes for
us and guess what when people walked out
of the movie sing Halloween they're like
it's fine when people walk out of the
scene the night comes for us
they weren't buzzing everybody and the
whole room was talking about it we
strangers regard strangers like can you
believe what we just saw that energy
that excitement will spread to every
person that sees it will spread by word
of mouth and this will be a movie that
we continue to talk about for years to
come as something that action fans and
non action fans will love to watch with
other people and it's not just about the
box office
it's about movies that will last and
kind of change the way we watch and
enjoy movies and something we remember
and that is the night comes for us Thank
You DJ Perry final thoughts I can tell
you that walking out of my tips
screening it was that same exact
reaction to Halloween and you know what
Halloween ticks both boxes it's gonna
have the money box and then on top of
that it's gonna have the legacy box and
we're gonna see the success of this
movie reverberate one with the
continuation of that franchise - with a
giving Blum house a nice boost and I get
tu so many are gonna want to try to
emulate what this movie accomplishes
with all of the slasher movies that have
been used and abused for years this
format and this movie in particular and
how good it is it gives them the
motivation to actually make a good one
they took the time they did it right
they respected the legacy and took it a
step further
thank you first of all that's the end of
round number one all right Dan
where are we sitting as far as
factuality we got a lot of factuality to
go through first of all as soon as the
show we're gonna be referring to fall
movie season I think in the next round
we might go into December that's because
a lot of times when people refer to the
fall movie season that takes us through
the end of the year so if you're curious
why there's things as November and
December here that's because that's sort
of the three segments is like spring
summer fall fall goes through the end of
the also we're in Los Angeles where
there are no season
pair you were right on the money how
Elaine's budget is at ten million
dollars currently tracking at a fifty to
sixty million dollar opening those
numbers always change as you get closer
but that's where it is currently as far
as the reception currently on Rotten
Tomatoes it is at 85% with 52 reviews
and including Perry's with an average
rating of 7.2 so that's the reception
that's on the board insider trading
though I'm sure it was all part of a
conspiracy to win this round
the first movie fights shout out to the
Great British Bake Off watch your soggy
bottoms this is the eleventh film in the
Halloween franchise Ivan Drago had three
nicknames that I could find yes Siberian
Express East Siberian bull and death
from above
I definitely love it I'm very Express
when I say agree to a 2014 survey said
that the average American adult reported
that they went to five movies and the
previous year however and there are a
lot of more options now streaming
options so that number could have
changed but that was the the most recent
year that I could find data for dan you
crushed it on the facts right there
make me sad five is at least a little
bit better go see more movies so yeah
you three three different movies so Josh
I mean I loved your passion there just
like you were selling me I'm like why I
would want to see the movie but I don't
feel like you sold why it would why
people would make it the biggest movie
of the fall every time I'm on here you
start like you know what Josh I really
like you and I want to date you but
you're not getting the point this round
DJ you almost had me with with it being
a big hit and the movie that people are
gonna be talking about but I feel like
you know Perry had a great knock against
you as well as Josh saying you know it's
a Netflix movie how's it going to do
that and maybe if you cited like oh the
way making a murder became a phenomenon
and I'm season one of daredevil gave him
a phenomenon but you didn't get specific
enough for that so I just couldn't
envision it breaking out but Perry you
had a great opening round I feel like
you clinched it for me with your final
round salvo there's nowhere that Perry
is actually the Siberian Express when it
comes through the face she's got my vote
for Halloween right here Dan Merle I
think that DJ you you you kind of gave
yourself an extra burden of proof in the
area with just all you had to not only
argue about why this movie connected
with people why it would transcend being
on Netflix and find that audience and I
don't think you quite got there for me
so it was between Perry and Josh and you
know I think he both spoke very well to
how each of the films would speak to the
bass to the fans of the franchise but
between the two I actually think that
Josh persuaded me a little bit more as
to why the average person might connect
to that why it might be more appealing
to just the everyday movie goer on the
street so I actually ended up edging
toward Josh another all right
all right we are one one that means we
are going to the fan pulled it aside fan
poll one last time right now it was neck
and neck between Halloween and Crete to
us a little time
and it is closed for tea the 49% winning
out this one is Creed - so Josh when -
all right Kouga you take them excited
very excited for both these movies but
you go see the night comes away super
excited pretty ambulatory key my only
good thing about my l22 eco always being
in my own suit the only thing that made
that will be bearable to watch so would
you watch this movie it's not it's not
it's this whole stunt team that
choreographs the sequences they'll blow
your mind
Wow awesome movies I was Halloween on a
fantastic factoid never seen a Halloween
movie incorporators scores the new one
right exciting all right question number
two so we talked about the biggest hit
what will be the biggest disappointment
of the fall movie season biggest
disappointment of the fall movie season
question to start with player - Josh
McKoon as much as this pains me to say
because I want it to be very very good I
think the biggest disappointment is
gonna be Aquaman but that's my Aquaman
impersonation that's him talking
underwater oh god you like that I just
you know I thought he was underutilized
in Justice League we haven't really had
any kind of an origin and or cool story
with him and I know this is probably
gonna be his origin story so I might
kind of counterbalancing myself but I
there was nothing in this trailer that
gets me excited it feels like it's too
busy there's there seems like there may
be two even three villains
he's fighting his brother I don't know
if it's his mom or a sister there's just
so many different characters and then
they had that
Oh welcome to Atlantis it just looks
like that underwater place in Phantom
Menace and I'm not like I'm not super
excited for what I've seen thus far in
the trailers that and the fact that DC
is very hit-or-miss Wonder Woman hid
Justice League miss you know Suicide
Squad miss there's there's something
about this movie where there's not a lot
behind it that gets me excited as far as
being able to trust them on a standalone
because I know I might be in the
minority or a split but I thought Man of
Steel was an absolute joke that movie
was terrible Batman V Superman was
terrible
I just don't know what they're able to
do with with Aquaman it's gonna change
my mind
and that being said to James Wan is
really been striking out at the plate a
lot for me too recently so this Aquaman
the movie does not look like something
that I think is gonna be the breakout
hit of the fallen and all honestly I
think a lot of comic book fans are gonna
go to see Aquaman and be very
disappointed all right it's Aquaman
gonna drown DJ listen non personal
opinions there you mean like even some
of DC's movies that people consider
misses still made a lot of money
superhero movies in general tend to make
a lot of money no matter where they're
coming from whatever I can tell you a
movie that's probably not going to do
well even critical reception or money is
Robin Hood because I couldn't even tell
you who's directing it and most it
reminds me of his King Arthur which also
bombs at the box office I was surprised
to see that Warner Brothers was also
producing this I was kind of assuming it
was like a shared universe thing was
going on it is not and Studios keep
trying to try it out these old try and
true King Arthur Robin Hood and people
don't care people don't want to see them
and they are not good enough to overcome
the the negative perception people
already have they would rather see a
venom or Aquaman in theaters so I think
this movie is not critically not going
to do so great and it's definitely
financially not gonna do great okay
Robin and his men will not be marrying a
crane DJ Perry I think we're in trouble
with venom
if that whole turd in the win line
didn't do it for you it's the fact that
this movie isn't screening for critics
until really close to release and that
is almost
sure sign that it is not gonna live up
to the incredible amount of hype and you
know box office are not we're talking
about the biggest disappointment here
and this one with all the height
building towards one having Spider Man
go back into the MCU and then Sony
reinvigorating there I guess Spider Man
less Spider Man franchise over there
this is the first movie out of the gate
and when people just don't like it yeah
it might have a strong opening weekend
in terms of money making but if fans
don't like it this could absolutely
crush a significant long-term plan for a
studio that is kind of riding on some
sort of necessary success with the comic
book franchise
alright let's fight it out listen I
think I think with whether your personal
opinions aside are people people are
excited about these movies people will
go see these movies and people are
invested in these characters and I think
Aquaman is destined to be hit because
James wand whether you like this movies
or not the contrary movies still make a
buttload of money but none did
incredibly well and he just produced
that one I think his name attached with
my wife does not care at all about
superhero movies she saw Jason Momoa
with a shirt off and she's in alright I
think we'll go see this movie and in
venom I think will do well enough I
don't think it will do as badly as Robin
Hood is destined to do if you look at
other times people have trabaja Julie's
for crying out loud talking about
disappointments here not box office
failures disappointments you pull a
whole bunch of people out there there is
no doubt they are more invested in
seeing a good venom movie and a good
Aquaman movie than a good Robin Hood
Robin Hood movie that see I can't even
that has been so I pay attention to
everything that's coming out that has
been so not on my radar I almost
completely forgot I remember so when it
comes out and it bombs it can't be a
disappointment cuz I don't care I would
tend to agree with Perry in a certain
extent of Robin Hood I didn't know it
existed until I think I was at the
trailer I was in the I was on it before
a movie and I can't remember what movie
I saw it before but I was like wait a
second they're making another Robin Hood
they keep making these bombs like the
Russell Crowe one was terrible
without the Richard Marx soundtrack the
Kevin Costner one would have been
terrible but the thing about the Robin
Hood movies is there is no legitimately
no expectation everyone's like oh do
they make a Kingsman Robin Hood spin-off
because that's basically what this looks
like for Robin Hood's not back for me
though Perry
I don't it may have hype in our world
like the people that we know but outside
of outside of the the die-hard superhero
people somebody sees the term venom on a
on a cinematic marquee whatever though I
am I gonna see that crap movie because
they don't care there's no hype behind
venom
nobody cares you're exacting 260 million
dollars that's it but that's the diode
what I'm saying is that like a lot of
money discipline it like 190 again I
don't know facts all I know is my
thoughts and my thoughts are the Tom
Hardy cannot mumble his way through
another movie and have me want to see it
that trailer is ridiculous it is a giant
gelatinous jell-o cube that are the
kindergartners make during Halloween
time like so what you do is you put the
milk in and then you put the black
yellow and you make that thing it's
silly that movie is I think the diehards
will love it no matter what you've
listed off a series of DC movies that
not only made a lot of money
but the diehards care about and I think
venom will be another one of those
movies that are people are probably like
I can't understand it will make a lot of
money people will be excited about it
and will definitely be getting a sequel
we're not gonna get a venom sequel but I
wouldn't be surprised if venom crashed
and burned and then took everything else
so the other day that Deadpool everybody
loved it at the box office
inexplicably what I'm saying is that
Aquaman is like the tent pole for WB
right now going forward they have
nothing else in the works that people
are like oh my god
oh my gosh James Bond movie you saw
because as far as I know it's someone
who has seen almost all of his work his
bar hits a certain point maybe they're
not all perfect movies but it's always
I'm talking about you're taking that toy
what I'm you are talking about a beloved
beloved comic book character that nobody
wants to see bomb and that is going to
tank recognized comic book character
that people have middlesbrough
expectations for that you're taking an
actor to people like and you're making a
movie that looks a lot like guardians of
the galaxy underwater most of your
trailers look good that extended trailer
that they showed at Comic Con this year
that one had the entire audience
erupting a live-action Little Mermaid is
going to look the exact same as that
Aquaman underwater Atlantis see we're
talking about the excitement between
Aquaman and venom in the fact that
people are excited the fact that people
are not excited about Robin Hood still
means the point it's the studio that
sunk a lot of money into that movie if
it's meant to be a tentpole it's meant
to it is meant to start a franchise I
think of of three movies we're talking
about that is least likely to get its
sequel I think Robin Hood ass atop that
list
okay it has no chance like blank we said
in the last fight creed 2 and Ralph
breaks the internet that movie is gonna
get a stick exactly Aquaman is
definitely gonna get a sequel it won't
make money Ben and flipper Cory's
ten years now at the new home and
between no expectations and no money
it's going to end up being that blip on
the radar that comes and goes in
everybody completely forgets it ever
existed massive disappointment invest in
that movie too much at that point if
we're looking at lore though okay so
everybody knows the name Robin Hood
right a lot of people know the name
Aquaman a select few know the name venom
I'm talking outside of the realms my 10
buddies that have no idea about
superheroes or comic books know who
venom is from the source material they
probably know who venom is from
spider-man 3 which would make this an
even bigger disappointment if we saw
venom twice on the big screen and they
burn the lines any bombs he looks like
Ava Duvernay indifferent a Cara
Delevingne at the end of Cara Delevingne
at the end of Suicide Squad it's just
like throwing as long hands out there
Suicide Squad made money it will also
want an Oscar but nobody gave Robin Hood
and venom nobody cares
people care about Aquaman because he is
a stalwart in the Justice League WB
every feel feeling like emphasizes my
point on how it's going to be the
biggest movie I think the lack of
excitement both the the lack of interest
I think the amount of money in time and
and star power Jamie Foxx's in this
movie the investment in this movie I
think if you're talking about box-office
disappointment that you're talking about
critical reception will be the of the
movies this will have the lowest
critical reception this will have the
lowest box-office which I think makes it
the biggest disappointment over all of
these movies the fact that you guys even
forgot that it existed I think it's a
testament to how this will be the
biggest disappointment of the fall
season movie thanks TJ yeah background
to you moviegoers don't care about Robin
Hood nor does the studio because it
seems to be burying it so it can't be a
disappointment in either category and as
for Aquaman yeah people are invested in
Aquaman but based on everything we've
seen thus far there is nothing to hit
that that is going to be a failure
whereas venom we're right around the
corner from the release we've seen time
and time again then release promo
footage that just doesn't look good that
looks laughably bad where they
pronounced important words wrong and on
top of that these screenings are
happening so close to release that it's
almost always a bad sign a
disappointment on a villain movie that
nobody cares about you're talking about
a hero this is there there are so much
expectations for Aquaman
that when it bombs it's gonna be another
hit to the armor of WB being like what
can we do to make a franchise work all
we have is Wonder Woman that's all we
have we can't get somebody to stay in a
Batman suit we can't get anybody to do a
Superman movie all we have are these
ancillary characters like the sirens of
Johnny be good who knows what I'm saying
is that Aquaman I don't even know what
that I what I'm saying is that Aquaman
as far as both these there's a little
bit expectation for venom there's a
little bit of none for Robin Hood there
is a huge expectation for Aquaman so it
makes money great but if going forward
nobody gives a crap
and it still is another hit to the WB
cinematic superhero universe whenever
we're calling it now Aquaman is gonna be
another flop falling flat failure
that's the end of round 2 everybody
thank you Percival damn give us your
facts and go ahead and tell us what you
thought about this argument this new one
is directed by Otto Bathurst he's making
his feature directorial debut important
in television he directed a black mayor
that I ever saw about the prime minister
and the pig
lemony is coming to the Robin Hood
legend and Josh Richard Marx was not the
artist behind the classic song
everything I do I do it for you
that was another smoky boost 80s star
Bryan Adams right Bartz I know Richard
Marx did have a song of the No Way Out
soundtrack which also has Kevin Costner
so maybe you were thinking about my
judgment mmm this this everyone was very
passionate I felt again I think DJ made
a very good argument about a financial
disappointment but I think he I admired
a tactic of just like sort of defining
what a disappointment is but I think it
was a very narrow definition I thought
with Jackson Perry had a broader
definition of the you know the term
disappointment and I agree I think that
and DJ and Perry both kind of hit him
for this I think that Josh was sort of
under estimating the the interest of
venom to the benefit of his argument and
I said it with Perry I thought she made
the most well-rounded argument and
that's where Michael you're dead to me
Merle fantastic piece that was my other
choice yeah are you giving up now for
I'm just saying yeah two minutes on
fantastic that violates Levites rules
and bylaws yeah so I felt like I also
think DJ got dinged pretty hard with not
just that expectations aren't that high
for this movie so how are you going to
be disappointed inherently you can't be
that disappointed if the expectations
aren't that I and also it is coming back
out on a packed weekend a jam-packed
weekend with a lot of box office choices
so for me it came down to Josh and Perry
and Josh had me from his opening salvo
but then he started to get deigned
really hard and back on your heels as
far as like oh no
other WB movies we're looking forward to
and and then DJ said yeah people want to
see Mambo with his shirt off in James
Wan is a pretty good filmography so I
agree with Dan Perry had the strongest
argument for me so Perry you take that
point right let us know what people
thought with the poll and then any other
choices they haven't yet they were kind
of the main argument they were having
the chat was the same of like whether or
not yeah you need the expectations too
for like to count up for what the
questions asking or not and they came to
the same conclusion they had a venom at
47% on the poll with the most amount of
votes Robinhood DJ's answer was just a
couple behind it 40% in an Aquaman at 11
Wow and Robin Hood the first minute of
that trailer and watching I'm like wait
a second this Robin Hood and then all of
a sudden that Robin of Locksley I'm like
yeah hey Ryan
yes can you say hi to Percival hi hi
first of all I Ryan great let's move on
to round number three Josh was one point
Perry was one point DJ looking to get on
the board with all right everybody is
excited about the house with the clock
in its wall it's number one at the box
office so we're asking what's the best
movie with the worst title okay
best movie with the worst title DJ this
is surprisingly a tough one because you
can find a lot of bad movies with bad
titles but having a good movie with a
bad title is challenging so I went with
what I think is one of the best movies
of last year which was baby driver which
if you just told me the title I'd be
like no thank you
it makes you sound like what baby boss
or something and
actually get is a fantastic musical
action heist caper it's Edgar Wright's
own take on a musical and a heist movie
the cast Estella the action is stellar
the pace in the cellar takes a lot of
like classic songs and uses them in ways
that you feel like you haven't heard
them before
and still the title is not good sure
it's a reference but a reference does
not a good title make alright and so if
you just told somebody baby driver
they'd immediately write this movie off
and it is truly a great movie that
deserves a better title all right Thank
You DJ around a parry I went with a very
obvious choice for this one for obvious
reasons it's edge of tomorrow which is
it's hands-down one of the worst worst
titles that actually hurt the movies
box-office it didn't fall flat on its
face but it definitely could have made a
little more money had they just gone
with the genius title that was live die
repeat and it's a legacy that's gonna
follow this movie for the rest of times
because if you go and you look up this
movie pretty much anywhere the boxart
for it says in bold live die repeat and
then at the bottom you'll get Emily
Blunt Tom Cruise and edge of tomorrow
nobody knows what to call this movie any
more to the point that I'm pretty sure
there was a mistake made on the Schmo
down at some point where someone said
one or the other and then it didn't
count they had such a good title the
movie itself is great too I watched it
last night for the first time in a
really long time and Wow what a genius
concept and who would have expected him
to nail the comedy and that movie so
well but it was a great great movie with
a terrible title and that title will
carry on for a long time thanks Perry
Josh well I'm going a little farther
back into the in the annals of history
their annals animals are nasty
I'm going with an 80s classic don't tell
Mom the babysitter's dead now you're
thinking yourself why is this idiot
talking about this movie in your and
you're probably right because it's not a
recent movie but if you look at the
poster this and you actually watch this
movie this movie really has nothing to
do with the babysitter being dead the
babysitter dies so early in the movie
and it's really just a coming-of-age
tale about a family put against their
backs and how to care for themselves and
figure out who they are as people while
also coming together as a family and
realizing who they are as a family all
while having no adult supervision and it
honestly made probably a generation
people realize they don't really even
need babysitters you have you the older
sister watch the kids and everybody
turned out fine and that's how it worked
in my family and this movie is
absolutely this this movie is absolutely
fantastic Christina Applegate in a very
very young role some awesome cameos like
a David Duchovny and all that kind of
stuff but this movie really is one of
the most underrated coming-of-age
classics with the worst titles I
remember thinking myself don't tell Mom
the babysitter's that is just some
stupid horror movie I'm gonna get scared
I know it's just an amazing movie that
really has a ton a ton of heart are
there plot holes sure but every movie
that is in the 80s has a bunch of plot
holes what this movie has again is just
plain heart alright fight it out y'all
so what criteria are you under here the
worst title or the best movie that also
has because I've gotten got dinged on
the criteria okay man I mean I
appreciate you asking there's a little
bit of gray area though you have to be
true to the question bad title good
movie because I think by and large my
movies the best out of these three
easily alright so when was the last time
you watched don't tell Mom the
babysitter's day just like a couple
years ago it's on TV like all the time
wait
you're wrong that's a great title don't
come on the babysitter's dead it's fine
it kind of gets the the tone of the
movie it's like really cool title make
me interested in seeing it well I I've
always grown up so I didn't obviously
see it when I was super young but I had
heard the title and become so familiar
with it because it catches your ear
eventually I did watch it while I still
to this day have some fun with that
movie this is probably a risk to do but
I'll give you this you have the best
movie at this table but if you're
pairing the best movie with the worst
title its along the rivers done doubt it
is edge of tomorrow even the director of
that movie has come out and given quotes
saying I fought the studio tooth and
nail to have that title change I lost
that battle and then it was after the
fact when the movie didn't make enough
money at the box office that they were
like oops let's use the edge of tomorrow
is less a problem of title and more
problem of marketing because the way
that movie was marketed on the
billboards it's sad to live die repeat
came to recognize within the audience I
think it's fine driver at least is one
that it can shake off because at this
point because also that's Edgar Wright's
biggest movie of all time so baby driver
now you go out and you start talking
about it baby truck cool you like baby
driver where is edge of tomorrow you can
go and say that to people and they still
get confused what's edge of tomorrow do
you mean live die repeat here's the
thing
with baby driver the movies good until
the third act and I mind of losing me
I'm not a really big fan because I want
him to anyway
I can't just cuz I will always want the
bad guys win but ok baby driver
I would watch no matter what you said
baby boss hysterical baby driver like oh
they made a sequel to be positive car
now that doesn't
but then you give me the actual movie
baby driver like it sold me and your
tomorrow I mean you could sell me the
whole seat but I'm only gonna need the
edge kind of a thing
edge of tomorrow is is a great on the
marquee I see edge of tomorrow like I
don't let's check this out I wonder what
the end of tomorrow is I bet it sounds
awesome don't tell Mom the babysitter's
dead you're like oh god this movie so
stupid but then you get in there and you
have this heartwarming tale of a family
coming together all whilst the the
oldest daughter is searching for her
identity in the crazy world of New York
fashion my team's recordable tale where
where as edge of tomorrow is just filled
with smart surprises and the problem
with you no edge of tomorrow I think is
Mark's approach yes I get what you do
live die repeat that goes into the
genius of the idea not really though but
that could have been the name of
Groundhog Day too
you don't see people going like positive
repeated tomorrow always goes to the
edge of tomorrow but never quite
marketing again my baby driver it just
doesn't quite I'm genuine of like oh
yeah just tomorrow I'm saying like I was
like in the theater no I did it okay I
mean okay I do tomorrow and baby driver
have these unthink that are too nice
thing can sync it's succinct titles
they're like BAM baby driver awesome and
to tomorrow Oh what is on the edge don't
someone they don't even ask
they don't even not tell the Mom the
babysitter's dead they only have one
phone call it the mother throughout the
whole movie these kids on the home
because the babysitter's dead you get
that through the title weekend at
bernie's keep the babysitter alive that
he's dead we don't even know and only
now it doesn't even matter the
babysitter is the first five minutes
movie nobody gives a crap tomorrow or
the babysitter's dead it's the same
it's also like but he's not a baby he's
like he's like I called yeah and also I
don't think that's a great name for that
character movie itself like trying to
get be trying to get the reference in
there they give a character a weaker
name that doesn't really fit the
character if I met someone named baby I
would never forget the name and that is
exactly what happened with baby driver
which is why every single time I say
that title I feel cool because I love
that movie Harry go ahead and continue
with your final thoughts edge of
tomorrow is a terrible title so bad that
the director and the studio eventually
realized it and it's a situation where
it's never going to be an issue that
fixes itself the movie is never going to
last and have that legacy so so strong
that people eventually forget about hey
even all you need is kill which is what
the book was originally titled live die
repeat now we have all these three
muddied up titles that are constantly
being considered and it's unfortunate
because who knows if doug liman got his
way and they titled that movie live die
repeat it would have sold the smart
concept of the movie in a flash and it
might have gotten more butts in seats
Thank You Josh don't tell Mom the
babysitter's dead is an absolute classic
with an absolutely horrendous title
because no parent today flipping these
things be like hey mom I want a match a
movie called don't Imam the babysitter's
dead has it be caught has it been called
something a little more family-friendly
a little more mainstream I think we
would have had the long-lived cult
classic of this movie whereas you were
like oh don't tell my the way verses
that that's pretty good no it could have
been absolutely fantastic but with a
title like that it really sold it short
Thank You DJ don't tell Mom the
babysitter's that is a classic title for
a fine movie a perfectly decent movie
edge of tomorrow is easy is a funny
title for for a fun movie we're all so
that's a problem of marketing you can't
put that you can't assume the other tie
was better by the way it did fine it's
getting a sequel even though it was a
stand to be staying alone movie so it
clearly did well enough
with the bad marketing of the title
whereas as baby driver is a title that
doesn't sell what the movie is it turns
people off from the movie and could use
a better title to better illustrate the
type of movie that it is which I'd like
to point out we all agreed at the table
was the best movie of the three time
that's the facts just a couple facts
Doug Liman
did claim subsequently in an interview
his side of the story is that he always
wanted to call it live die repeat but
Warner Brothers may have made them call
it edge of tomorrow and then realized
too late that they made a mistake and
the sequel that is being developed is
now called limp die repeat repeat I
think also a terrible first boy to Rambo
like that and outside of the cuca world
yes the movie baby boss is known as the
boss baby
I kind of think baby boss is a better
name thank you so yeah this was this was
a real fun fight I think you know Perry
I was I was I was fully with you but you
hit why the title didn't work but you
didn't hit best movie enough I think
Josh you got ding this don't tell Mom
the babysitter's dead even though it is
a mouthful and stuff it's it hangs
around it's an iconic title you know
what my original choice is gonna be with
Zack Guardians of Ga'Hoole the owls of
ga'hoole the person who made the the
best argument for bad title and good
movie that combo was DJ for me so DJ you
get my vote damn yeah if I'm getting
ready for it the queues us all the time
we're doing this on purpose but I swear
it is based on every argument but I
think the person that argued worst title
best movie was DJ so I'm gonna have to
agree with you it's not a con game
that's just how it works see I'm with
you portal yeah so DJ you take the point
Ryan get that pull off and ready I want
to know what it is but I will go on the
record though and say that I think baby
driver is overrated
I actually prefer edge of tomorrow to be
a driver Ryan what's the public have to
say which I was kind of feeling the same
way you were actually I think the chat
mostly the conversation for them was
arguing what they thought of the three
answers was actually the best movie I
think they would read for the most part
that baby driver was is a weird title
but they actually thought the edge of
tomorrow for the most part was a better
movie they didn't have being 46% for
edge of tomorrow 37% for baby driver and
16% for don't tell Mom the baby's edges
tomorrow's a blast and also don't tell
Mom the babysitter's know that is really
fun it's a really fun classic this movie
fight because we are all tied up 1 1
billion I told you on email sports we
are going to the tiebreaker
so the tiebreaker works thusly I will
throw out the question and then shout
out your answers and then the first
person to answer will go everyone will
get 20 seconds and then we'll go back
around for 10 second rebuttals okay so
20 second answers 10 second rebuttals
works just like a speed round
so I'll ask the question let us know
what your answer is ready there we go
what non-superhero character should bond
with the Venom symbiote in a new movie
what non-superhero character so existing
movie character who's not a superhero
should bond with the venom cynic John
wick Dwayne the rock Johnson Oh what
character a character Hobbs fast
inferior greatly of Hobbs
John wick Charlize Theron in atomic
blonde atomic blonde great so we heard
John wick first and then we'll go to DJ
with Hobbes and then Charlize an atomic
blonde Perry John wick is one of the the
most badass assassin killers we've
gotten in a while here he has all these
incredible incredible abilities all on
his own what way do you up the ante with
a guy like John wick then by
with the symbiotes and making him kind
of like venom whereas you know someone
like the rock yeah we already know he's
bad as he Hulk's out all the time we see
him throw stuff around DJ the people
John wick is Keanu Reeves of physical
performance is doing the practical
action if you had Hobbs do it you
wouldn't even need to do CGI on dwayne
johnson you can put him in an actual
suit his physicality matches venom you
could get a practical venom on the big
screen which i think we could all agree
would be better than a crappy cg venom
and you can still have dwayne johnson
doing all the amazing stuff he does hops
as them okay i think what we're lacking
within venom is a spy ish kind of a
person where they fly under the radar
whereas charlize theron an atomic blonde
is that silent killer she comes she
kills she walks away kind of walk away
from the explosion she gets in that
symbiote then she's this beautiful
blonde again nobody knows that she's the
symbiote and they can't tell they just
can't tell alright ten second rebuttals
Perry Charlize Theron has some kick-ass
action scenes an atomic blonde but that
character is thin and dull and I don't
care anything about her whereas John
wick is layered and he earned my heart
from the second he stepped on screen in
the first movie AJ Hobbs is already one
of the most iconic anti-heroes we've
gotten in this decade and having him be
able to play a practical venom of it
would do a service to the venom
character and to the character of Hobbs
you wouldn't you wouldn't take from
either
I can't see a Venom symbiote on Hobbs it
just it does not work for me as far as
thinly-veiled she's perfect John wick
doesn't need venom that ruins him that
ruins my job
okay so Ryan we're gonna you're gonna
give us your opinion instead of the poll
no time for polls right now so Ryan what
is your thought and tell us who does not
move on who does not move on
all right I like I like Tamiya was
trying to figure out like who would be
the most interesting once you add the
symbiote on top of them and I like DJ's
argument of being like out of those
three characters that like the rocks
that sees already has such a brutal kind
of like physical type of body I get any
practical venom I think that would be
cool where it's like with John wick and
Shirley throne I don't think like I
would I think I really like him exactly
like how they are so I think DJ would
have gotten the point but if I have to
choose between the two to who I wouldn't
have move on I think I would have to go
Josh just because I think they're at
least John wick would be a more
interesting character to duel with the
symbiote like internally adalah two of
those Dan actually the first person that
I would advance is Josh because I think
of the three he gave the best vision of
what a use would be which is that you
would use her existing spy skills but
the Venom symbiote then would be like
this thing that they're looking for and
I kind of like the combination so I
would advance Josh so the person that I
would not advance that now becomes to me
between DJ and Perry and I just I don't
know I just I was not sold on practical
venom I don't that argument just did not
sway me very much and I felt like so
much of DJ's argument was based solely
on that idea of a practical venom so I
would advance Josh and Perry and I would
not advance DJ Whoo so okay one for one
for one for DJ not moving on one for
Josh moving on yeah at the at the end of
the day I feel like yeah I really like
Josh's always also my favorite I like
the idea of just like smooth Charlize
Theron just kicking ass and then having
that symbiote to come back Adam so
between these two yeah I think I gotta
side with Dan a similar way of thinking
DJ I'm sorry you are not moving on but
well-fought always great
yes so and I might come to you for your
for an opinion as to your thought as we
go into the speed round
let's do this this is brother-sister
fight this is to hit the speed round
alright and that voice is the there's no
points it's not count for anything it is
1 1 it is 1 1 going into this speed
round and the rules work similarly to
what we just did first person out gets
to give their answer in its twenty
second twenty second and then ten second
rebuttal ten second rebuttal y'all ready
for this thank you
alright question number one of the speed
round the new Dark Phoenix trailer
dropped today which is the better new
cast x-men flick first class or Days of
Future past Days of Future past
well first class without a doubt okay
Perry you spoke first for Days of Future
past 20 seconds will begin when you
speak now Days of Future past this is
your brilliant movie that shouldn't work
because it is the new class and the old
class in it and it ties them all
together so so well we're the new class
and the old class wind up enhancing each
other
so the perfect passing of the baton for
that franchise I couldn't believe they
pulled it off and some of those
performances are some of the best
performances we've seen in the entire
x-men franchise thus far Michael
Fassbender Jennifer Lawrence James
McAvoy crushing time x-men in the new
class first class our last my first
class right that is without a doubt the
best origin story we've seen in the
franchise that movie should not work
really and the fact that we're throwing
it back to all these young x-men and
they totally pull it off together
there are superstars in that movie but
they all come together to make that
movie perfect excellent first-time
fantastic definitely not all of them cuz
if I recall January Jones is in that
movie and she's not a lot of fun to
watch at all
excellent Days of Future past is the
well is the much more well-constructed
movie the franchise we're arguing cast
here you're throwing all the old cast
and then they're dynein they do an
inception thing and really doesn't
together they're fighting these titans
that are shooting right all of them
together it seems like such a separate
movie first class are coming together to
kill the nots hi Cuba alright so I feel
like I heard just a little bit more
about different aspects of the film so
best answer for me was Perry going with
Days of Future past Dan I would also
agree with that boy and I think Perry
has the better argument there it was
close it was but Perry takes the lead
two to one its first player to four here
we go question or two the new cream -
yes trailer drop this week's what is the
best sequel / spin-off of the rocky
franchise what creed okay so we have
rocky 4 vs. Creed mokuba's you spoke
first rocky 4 when you break that movie
down is like about 5 minutes of actual
spoken word big twixt 5 of the greatest
montages musical training and/or
montages in movie history and in one
boxing match he solves communism he
tears down the Berlin Wall he tears down
the Iron Curtain rocky 4 is the Jerry I
love the first rocky movie and pretty
much every single one after that is a
little bit of a blur to me and then
Creed comes along and all of a sudden
Creed once of reinvigorating my love of
that franchise because all of a sudden
this other movie so many years later out
of the blue has really strong character
development for its new character brings
back Sylvester Stallone in a movie that
earned him an Academy Award nomination
rocky for was the point in the franchise
when they thought they couldn't do it
again and they did create it was kind of
a surprise but without for without what
rocky did in four we don't even get
Creed you could say that about any
franchise out there but what Creed is
doing right now it's taking what the
first rocky movie started to establish
and it's running with it that's why it
was your answer for our first question
today because Creed is so good you are
so hyper critical
Ryan yeah I think I have to go with
paradise more specifics about the actual
movie all right you know I don't know if
we can fact check if it ended comedy I
was alive during that time so I'll have
to take your word for it but I do think
overall they're worse I think she's
working to do about the actual movie and
that made it clear I think was Perry
Thank You Ryan
damn yeah two weeks four years what's
that yeah oh man I have to take myself
out of it cuz I've been very open about
the fact how much I love Rocky Ford it
is my personal favorite but based on the
arguments I gotta go with Perry though
to Rocky three with clubber Lang that's
a good news cover under lips I also feel
like Rocky 2 is very underrated a little
more subtle than the more bombastic
sequels on we can all agree that Rocky 5
is junk okay so it is some 3-1 Perry
this is game point so Josh you need to
continue this hard question you need
this to continue the game you think I
need something you guys have anything
I'm there about summer catch or airborne
what do you got
I have this question for you Oh even
more trailers okay new trailer for
bumble bee drop this week a little John
Cena bumblebee action what would be the
worst object to transform into if you
were a transformer what would be the
worst thing to be the objects to
transform into be careful is the famous
Photoshop and in an air conditioning
unit in America
Oh window unit not even a central a/c
just those window units
it's looking me in the face right now an
empty red Bull can okay okay okay an
empty red Bull can Josh you spoke first
20 seconds begin when you speak now in
the summer time the AC unit is great it
keeps it cool and it also drips on the
sidewalk or outside wherever and ruin
somebody's day when it rips in their
eyeball in the wintertime you know store
that AC unit somewhere or it's stays in
your window and just collects dust it is
the worst AC unit transformer terrible
an AC you like okay boom an AC unit gets
a whole lot of love because it provides
you with wonderful cool air for a really
long time whereas a Red Bull can clearly
it only lasts so long you know what's
gonna happen to this Red Bull can after
we walk off this set it's gonna go in
the trash that's it's actually gonna get
recycled but one way or the other it's
never coming back its life is over this
is it bye bye Red Bull ten second
rebuttal nobody the Red Bull can it's
just it already had energy in it but it
can transform be like oh it's under and
I don't know this is
doesn't get wings the person who drinks
it get wing people take care of it so it
keeps running I would want to be an AC
unit so I would get taken care of time
Wow toilet yeah I mean I mean Josh
you're just exasperated just like
explosion they're kind of like just put
all the chips in my mind over to Perry I
gave it to Perry I yeah it was like
watching it's like well you know like
when you watch the Olympics sometimes
someone's old like the world like it's a
downhill skier and they're on a
world-record pace and then they they hit
that last jumper they come around the
last turn and then they just roll into
the side and the shower of snow yes
that's what I just witnessed yeah I feel
like hey I have to give it to Perry
congratulations well well played I like
to thank personal for the album yeah I'd
also like to thank thank first of all if
you could start following me on Twitter
then I also like to thank you thank you
Perry congratulations please give some
shoutouts tell us where we can find a
whole bunch of shout outs you can find
all my stuff on collider.com my own
personal YouTube channel and Collider
video of course where we have fyc the
new for your consideration show and if
you like are like me and not like Josh
McKoon oh you should check out Collider
witching hour I do it with a Hallie
foutch and it's on the the collider
factory podcast network awesome sounds
spooky and delightful yes Congrats
well-fought perry is it is this your
first movie fights victory second third
um I think it might be my first official
movie fight Spectre I think I had a TV
feat TV fights one and then like another
at the event you guys did it oh yeah
that small round round
you crushed it thank you so much nicely
done Josh you were you're always the
light fall yeah and I just love hearing
you speak I'm sorry I'm sorry to all
those those air conditioning units out
there that I may have offended a lot of
air conditioners down there I have no
idea how to fight in a red book and
that's where I lost a lot of marbles
there LA the red bullpen would be right
in line with the amount of product
placement that they have and some of
this Josh please go ahead and tell us
where you can find you give some shout
out yeah Josh from Kouga Twitter
Instagram the Jessamine Cougars show on
YouTube I'm all over Collider clutter TV
talk clatter live Monday through
Wednesday and John Cooper jeopardy
hashtag it I gave you all these guys
buttons if you see me I've got all kinds
of different swag that I can give to you
guys I jump on your social medias take a
picture just tag jeopardy or hashtag it
Josh mood for jeopardy
Josh McKoon for Jeopardy hashtag John
from Google for Jeopardy
DJ Woolridge always a pleasure having
you in here have some great answers you
turned me on to a Netflix movie that I'm
really looking forward to now Yeah right
please give some shoutouts tell us where
I can find you so you can find me at
only soup answers like I said it's a
podcast for me and Sam bash we're
talking about movies comic books and TV
shows we also also do a live show which
is going on I'm like right now so when
you're done watching this you can go to
twitch.tv slash play noggin and you can
catch you mentioned TV fights Roxy
Striders over there she hosts that show
with us so and you can listen to a
podcast on Mondays for all that just got
only stupid answers.com
excellent DJ always great to have you
dan Burrell give some shouts so many
shout shout out to everyone watching
thank you for watching yes thank you
yeah that's what you can watch this some
screen junkies
news every morning's sju on Twitter oh
and I I want to make sure we don't
forget how yeah this may be in your
notes too but if you watch that speed
round and you felt like you had a
question that you would have liked to
have seen our competitors answer we are
now taking fan suggestions for speed
round questions to use in future
episodes so if we had a good speed round
question it can be in this or that it
can be a we haven't done a bargain bin
question too long yeah they could
anything that
and your head you think we'd be good for
the show comment down there and if you
see one that you like about it so it'll
help us see it but yeah we want to get
you involved in helping us pick some
speed round questions oh hell yeah
are we allowed to submit speed round
questions on moving fights that we're
not involved
yes ones that you're not involved with
sure we'll take a look so it would be a
lot of Billie's a nurse up here a lot of
a nurse I love some easy Rhino tools
thank you so much for stepping in and
being the voice of the people yeah you
held it down my man um please get some
shouts hey shout out to Danielle for not
being here
no worries people the chance she will be
back and the dankmemes will follow I
didn't want to take her bread and butter
that sort of thing thanks for having me
and if you wanna check something out I
just did ed careers nerd goat podcast I
just didn't upset on Captain America
with Ed so that was a lot of fun very
cool thank you sir
I wanna I want to thank everybody for
watching I want you to please tune in
next week because we are having a
special show the debut deathmatch we're
gonna have a bunch of first-timers on
and they're gonna be competing for
something special and yeah we'll see who
who came to play who makes an auspicious
beginning and who walks away never to
movie fight again I wanna thank Billy
biz in the booth holdin it down yes
absolutely JT e we're thinking about you
and I hope you've finished the new
spider-man video game by now with all
your time to play it and I want to thank
my little friend first of all by
Percival Ryan Oh God can we be friends
yes
friend you guys I want to say hit me up
on Twitter and Instagram and we'll see
you next week a movie fights my life bye
you